up until recently north korea's leader
would never be seen in public wearing a
mask but now king jong-un can no longer
avoid it
local media is calling it an explosive
outbreak of covet 19.
dozens of people have died with more
than eight hundred thousand suspected
cases
the government has ordered a strict
lockdown but cases are spreading fast
on state television a doctor recommends
gargling with salt water if suffering
from a fever
with a crumbling health care system a
malnourished population and no vaccines
experts worry the pandemic could have a
devastating impact on north
korea the outbreak could lead to
shortages and an economic crisis in
order to prevent that the government's
conducting food rationing measures
but the surge in infections didn't stop
the government from testing its weapons
just hours after announcing the outbreak
on thursday it fired three ballistic
missiles off its east coast
this indicates that the country will
likely conduct missile tests more
frequently to counteract the depressed
atmosphere caused by covet 19 among
north korean citizens
the first cases of the omicron variant
were reported in april in its capital
pyongyang
the same month the city hosted several
large public celebrations where most
people did not wear masks
at the time cases were soaring in
neighboring china north korea's biggest
trade partner and close ally
we will pay close attention to the
developments of the epidemic in north
korea and maintain communication with
their government to protect the lives
and the health of our citizens who live
there
most of north korea's 26 million people
are not vaccinated the world health
organization offered inoculations last
year but kim jong-un rejected it
for now there's no sign people living in
the most isolated nation in the world
are closer to getting any help
katie lopez odan al jazeera